this giant stone wall on the coast will
be eight kilometers long when it's
finished it's an important part of the
eco Atlanta city development project on
the shores of Lagos it's designed to
protect the new resort area the walls
construction is about half finished
david frame is the project manager he
says it'll take more than 100,000 cement
blocks to finish it away five tons each
trait is designed so they belong
together
so they work in
creates a very formidable defense
against the aggressive wave action a
hundred years ago there was no
development here but due to the rising
sea level the beaches have been
disappearing and are now being restored
most of the property Lots here have
already been sold the Victoria Island
district the city's main business and
financial center is located right next
door to the project
it used to be surrounded by water and
swamps
so the Eco Atlantic City Development
will benefit Victoria Island as well
we are reclaiming this land protecting
Victoria Island but in addition to that
we are creating the necessary expansion
so the commercial activity and the
expansion of residential accommodation
within lagos can be achieved to a very
high level when the project is completed
Eko Atlantic City will be home to about
250,000 people another 150,000 will
commute to and from work here it's a
multi-billion dollar project financed by
private investors and the Nigerian
government Lagos is already one of the
world's most expensive cities and only
the truly wealthy will be able to afford
to live in Eko Atlantic City there will
be none of the heavy traffic or
overcrowded housing projects found in
other parts of the city
for generations Sony Alec AJ's family
has lived in a poor district near the
coast not far from the new construction
site there used to be a lot of houses
around here a street used to run over
there where the water is the ocean just
kept rising and rising the people who
live here can't afford a wall to protect
them so during big storms the water
comes in and swallows up more and more
of the land and local residents say that
all the construction just down the road
has made the situation worse marine
ecologist eco Ahmadi says this coastal
area is under threat he adds that the
Atlantic City project may have
contributed to coastal erosion we make
observations but we don't find the
causes of the observations which we are
making so the erosion has become so
progressive nobody has been measuring it
in research and this is a problem that
we have here that we should have had a
lot of cumulative research to actually
show the progression of what is
happening what we have seen is that
every year the people who live in these
areas have had to move backwards
property has been destroyed and there's
actually no solution to it right now
David frame says coastal erosion is a
serious problem in Nigeria but denies
that his project is making it worse the
entire coastline of Nigeria is
undergoing quite serious erosion and
it's something that needs to be
addressed what we're doing in Echo
Atlantic in our small part we are
protecting the commercial area and the
existing conurbation of Lagos but we
cannot protect the entire Leckie
peninsula some experts predict that the
sea level could rise here by one meter
the question remains how will Lagos meet
this challenge
you